my plane is totally different from
anything they were taught a dog on the
ground
the dogs got to learn some totally alien
babies we're gonna be 3,000 feet in the
air
we've got turbulence sheer drops we
don't get the right dogs we're dead
Joan Babette
Barry Cameron hello to you Barry thanks
for joining us this afternoon
um I'll bet you've met quite a few dogs
I'm sure can a dog that you've met ever
fly a plane do you think I must admit to
be slightly skeptical I think the
experts would suggest it the more
intelligent dogs might have the brain
processing power of a toddler so if a
toddler was flying a plane I'm not sure
I'd be jumping on another absolutely
what sort of skills do you think that
dogs have that might better able them to
fly aircraft a couple if I'm having this
conversation with you but what do you
think well I spoke to some good
qualities that some of them have not all
obedience lip listening skills
problem-solving and but yeah I think
some of the more complex tasks might be
out of reach of the in the most
intelligent pooch but I suppose it
remains to be seen
do they understand the consequence do
you think uh I'm not sure they
understand the consequence of not
keeping the plane in the air I imagine
these sorts of things are quite
experiential and they probably haven't
seen or experienced the consequences of
that so I don't think it I don't think
you really do know but in everyday life
presumably they do don't they I mean my
dogs they know that if they do something
wrong there are consequences
ya know I think in that in that sense in
a more basic sense they do so you know
if they if they do something in there's
a negative outcome and they experience a
negative consequence and they're less
likely to want to do that and the
reverse is true they do something to get
positive rewards they get a treat then
they're going to want to do that again
so so yeah at a basic level they
understand consequence understand fear
but I think a higher or more complex
level they they might struggle
you mentioned fear they're very I mean
jumping out of a plane on the
battlefield we've seen dogs are doing
that with their owners with with
parachutes on quite obviously do they
feel fear in the same way that humans do
I think probably a more again a more
basic level so yeah there are examples
of dogs you know Marine dogs who jump
out of helicopters and you know
Newfoundlands in Canada jump into the
water from boat rescue people so I think
if they enjoy it and then and you know
that there's a there's a positive
outcome from from them doing it then
they're more likely to want to do it
again so but I don't think they
understand in the fear and the
complexity that we would I don't know
you speak for yourself I think my dogs
or at least one of them is quite clever
as you know does it matter though do you
think if it's a mongrel or a an Irish
setter well I mean it's true to say that
some dogs are more easily trained than
than others and whether being able to
follow instructions is a is a measure of
intelligence is a different matter
and I think I think I'm right in saying
you have a soft spot for red setters so
I wouldn't be so bold as to suggest they
can accomplish the most complex part but
I think there's a little bit of breed
variation in it for that sort of thing
though yeah looking at the images as
were chatting to you we're actually
seeing these dogs they're actually quite
clever they one of them realized that he
couldn't reach a ball but he had a
platform so he took the platform closer
and then he could manage to get hold of
the ball so he managed him figure that
out well we're actually you can't see
these pictures but you'll have to trust
me very there are images of dogs
flying planes what particularly what is
as a vet and having seen many many
thousands of jobs over the years what
particularly is going to appeal to you
from this program do you think I think
as long as they can reach the autopilot
button with their nose and it will
probably be alright but now I'd be able
to see what they can actually what they
can actually pull off you know no one
really knows so prepare to be astounded
that of it it would be nice a nice bit
of a bit of TV gold if they could
actually do it yeah but you wouldn't get
on a triple seven if they were flying
the plane would you no no I think I say
the next flight it's great to told you
as always Barry thanks very much and
Dean for joining us on Sky News this
afternoon thanks long